[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american horror
thriller film called 13 sins
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins in perth australia
professor edgar solomon is welcomed to
make a speech in front of several people
at a party he recites a children's poem
about a rabbit and a bear but the crowd
gets uncomfortable when the poem gets
inappropriate he is stopped by a woman
beside him who is as surprised as
everyone else edgar apologizes and then
cuts one of her fingers off using a
knife her screams make everyone else run
away while the professor collects the
finger in a tissue the security guard
asks him to put his hands up and when he
doesn't oblige he is shot dead with his
last strength edgar tries to get to his
mobile phone but is unsuccessful parties
in australia look lit
elsewhere salesman elliot brindle lives
in new orleans louisiana he and his
fiancee are expecting to have a baby
soon and are about to get married in a
few days at such an important point in
his life eliot is told that he is fired
according to his boss he is too much of
an empath to be in sales meaning he
cares too much about how the customers
feel following that elliot goes home to
his mentally challenged younger brother
michael michael is his biggest
responsibility because he pays 1200
monthly for his outpatient care now that
he is unemployed michael is at risk of
being sent to a mental institution that
he dreads after the encounter elliott
drives to his abusive and racist father
samson to ask for help however he finds
out that samson has lost all of his
retirement funds and will now have to
move in with them at night elliot is
alone in the car when he is troubled by
a fly he gets a call from someone who
claims that he has been selected for a
one-of-a-kind game show that could make
him a lot of money at first elliott
thinks that the person is a scammer he
is about to end the call but stops when
the initiator recites all of elliot's
family history so he's a scammer and a
stalker he seems to know everything
significant that has happened in
elliot's life since his childhood
including the details about his mother's
fatal car accident at last he also talks
about the fly that has been bothering
elliott recently elliot is left
speechless the man claims that if he
kills the fly a thousand dollars will be
sent to his bank account without
thinking much of it elliot swats the fly
and kills it seconds later a
notification informs him that his bank
account has been credited with a
thousand dollars he quickly gets out of
the car to check if someone is spying on
him looking around he realizes that he
is in fact alone but if that is true
there is no way to explain the money in
his bank account the person says that
his next challenge is to swallow the fly
for exactly 3 622
elliot quickly gets in the car and
rushes back home he checks his computer
and sees that the thousand dollars are
still in his account he is in need of
money and also wants to check if the
initiator is legit hence he reluctantly
eats the dead fly he yet again gets the
phone call from the person
congratulating him for completing the
second task the money is soon
transferred to his bank account confused
by all this eliot inquires if he is
being watched even in his home the voice
says that he can get his privacy back if
he wishes to but that would mean he
would be disqualified from the game
following that he has briefed about the
rules of the game elliot will have to
complete a series of 13 challenges each
of which will result in greater rewards
if he fails to complete any of them
interferes in the game or reveals the
game to anyone else he will lose all the
money including any he has already won
since he has completed two challenges he
has only 11 more left if he wants to
continue the game he is asked to say i
will dance with the golden toad
well that clears it up the prank caller
must be luigi elliott does as said and
is registered as a contestant the next
day he is in a park with shelby and her
parents impatiently waiting for the next
call some minutes later he is told that
the third challenge for five thousand
dollars is to make a child cry he
excuses himself and starts looking for
the perfect child a little girl comes
running to him giving him the perfect
opportunity he tells her that her
parents are going to leave her in an
orphanage and makes her cry
elliot is a natural the child runs to
her parents while he receives the cash
prize he quickly gets in the car with
shelby to drive away as the parents yell
curses at him following that the pair
goes to the church to pick up elliot's
father he gets a call again and is told
that for the fourth challenge he should
burn a nativity scene hand-crafted by
blind kids for the church when no one is
looking elliot brings the structure
outside and burns it the fire
accidentally spreads around the church
and gets uncontrollable he quickly runs
away with his family after ringing the
fire alarm moments later ten thousand
dollars is credited to his account not
long after that he gets the next
challenge and is asked to follow a
homeless person by the side of the road
in the police station the little girl's
parents have come to report the incident
at the same time the homeless person
also arrives there detective chilcote is
told that someone stole the homeless
person's clothes and belongings when the
sketches of the felon are made they
realize that the person who stole the
clothes burned the church and troubled
the girl is the same elliot is now on
challenge six he is asked to take a man
from a specific apartment out for coffee
he believes that the challenge is too
easy but he soon realizes the catch the
person he is taking out is lying dead in
a bathtub with no way out he sprays a
freshener all over the corpse to hide
the smell he then dresses it and drags
it out in a wheelbarrow to the nearest
diner the waitress comes to take his
order and doesn't think much about the
dead guy because his face is hidden with
a hat elliot is given a deadline to
complete the mission hence the slow
waitress annoys him just then a group of
policemen enter the diner for lunch when
the coffee doesn't arrive till the last
second elliot snatches a cup from the
policeman's table the challenge is
completed but he is now in trouble with
the police they ask him to come out to
talk but he sees that they were drinking
on duty and calls them out at last he
manages to run away while arguing he
gets a call from the initiator who is
impressed by his skills hence he jumps
directly into the eighth challenge but
elliot's happiness doesn't last for long
when he is informed that he has left his
library card in the diner the police
will soon find him but if he completes
all the challenges the initiator will
let him free no matter what now his only
way to a free life is to complete the
challenges following that a van picks
elliot up and brings him to an unknown
location for his next mission back in
the diner the policemen find the corpse
and start to investigate detective
chilcote sees a strange man talking to
the waitress the waitress says that the
man was inquiring about elliot the
detective starts to follow the guy to
the trailer and finds that he has been
investigating the game he has found out
where it first started and what happens
to the people who play it however no
information about the initiator is
available in the meantime elliot is
taken to a room where he meets his high
school bully john it turns out his next
challenge is to cut off jon's arm he
doesn't even have to do it forcefully
because jon is volunteering to have his
arm cut off for money elliot is
definitely getting the better end of
this deal when elliott hesitates the guy
reminds him of all the ways he was
bullied making him do it after cutting
it off he drives john to the hospital he
receives 250 000 dollars for the mission
i wonder what john got then he drives to
his practice dinner for his wedding his
next mission is to trash the party in
front of everyone and urinate in one of
the flower arrangements the police
arrive looking for michael and accusing
him of public nudity elliott takes the
opportunity to help michael and distract
the police by trashing the party he
breaks all the cutlery and peas in the
flowers this way shelby thinks that he
is doing it for his brother when in
reality he's doing it for the challenge
he manages to run away from the security
but his next challenge is to surrender
himself he reluctantly goes back and is
arrested in the police station he is
interrogated about everything he did
throughout the day when he is accused of
things he didn't do he finds out someone
else is also playing the games when no
one is watching he breaks the bottom of
the chair and uses it as a weapon to
hold a policeman hostage at last he
jumps out of the window and lands on a
dumpster he loses his phone in the chase
and has no way to contact the initiator
just then he notices a homeless woman
walking by and assumes she was sent by
the initiator the two enter a trailer
nearby somewhere else detective chilcote
finds the conspiracy theorist fogler he
was looking for it turns out that his
wife had played the game some years ago
and died while playing it since then
fogler has been trying to find the
initiator back in the trailer the woman
asks elliott to hang a clothes hanger as
his next mission he does it but soon
finds out the string goes across the
road that a group of youngsters is
riding their bikes on if the string
stays there it will cut their heads off
elliott quickly removes the string not
wanting to kill people for the challenge
however the second person who is also
playing the game ties another string
across the road and brutally kills the
youngsters seeing their decapitated
bodies elliot wishes he'd done it for
the money just kidding elliott refuses
to continue the game he runs behind the
second player to stop him as well the
man gets in a van and drives away while
being followed by elliot the initiator
calls elliot on a phone that he had
stolen earlier to tell him about his
final mission he says that the last
mission is the same for all the players
he has to kill one of his family members
elliot ignores the call not wanting to
continue the game to his surprise he
sees the van parked in front of his
apartment building when he goes in he
finds his father in the living room and
michael in the bathroom he puts two and
two together and figures out that the
second player is michael michael still
wants to play the game and is ready to
shoot their father dead to win it to
their surprise the father claims that he
had also played the game many years ago
he won after killing their mother the
brothers are left speechless elliot gets
ready to kill him but the father cuts
his own throat to keep them from winning
elliot wants to end everything but
michael points his gun at him to win the
game while trying to make him understand
elliot accidentally shoots michael even
then the younger brother doesn't give up
he stabs elliot but dies in the process
elliot has finally completed all 13
challenges he limps away from the house
while being watched by detective
chilcote we find out that the detective
is also working for the game he has
killed fogler because he was too close
to finding out about the initiator
detective chilcote goes inside the house
to light michael and his father's body
on fire to erase the evidence before he
can eliot arrives and shoots him dead in
the last scene he calls shelby and tells
her that he is fine she informs him of a
phone call she received that morning
asking her to eat a fly elliot freezes
in shock but shelby says that she
declined the offer
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching